Davis four to shoot guarded by Draymond
Green makes the drive gets inside it's
good Anthony Davis another big bucket
Anthony Davis a lot of credit
started off hot and continued all game
long
that's key to me anybody facing this
Warrior team how disciplined will you be
defending to knock down Shooters on the
permit Anthony Davis nice move across
the lane so coming to mouth I did not
touch him but he's got two quick fouls
in his first minute Davis being very
aggressive Terence Houston scores got
five early points much more comfortable
than in his younger days of putting the
ball in the deck and creating offense to
pull himself off the dribble Davis jump
shot
[Applause]
Davis impacting the game offensively
early on aggressive don't worry about
this keep on playing
round misses that one kept Alive by
Vanderbilt picked up by Davis Curry got
leveled there inside passed of Annabelle
feeds Brown back shot no good but Davis
can clean it up
Louis hachimura in for the first time
[Music]
one of the in-season editions of Roy
Davis now five of seven from the field
to start well he fakes a handoff and
attacks and he's always been better
going left he's got that nice little
floater again they have the second
easiest remaining schedule in terms of
opponents 20 percentage the bad news of
course LeBron James not going to be
around as Davis with a beautiful block
but still with a Chance of making the
playoffs Sam said players uh agreed with
his assessment of that game and were
nodding their heads when he was calling
them out in the locker room and said he
just needs these guys to understand
what's in front of them every day
and you gotta identify those guys and
keep them and get rid of the ones that
don't play with anything because they'll
cost you your job in the season you are
a brand you have changed the life of not
only you but everybody around you
now take take responsibility and grow
from this being a better Pro and most
importantly a better man
Curry
beats the dribble finds coming Goods
Away by Davis Here Comes Reeves
Reeves continues toward the rim that
shot is good
[Music]
oh nice entry past Davis able to pack at
Home huge height advantage against
Anthony lamb greenford Davis
after the switch of the pick and roll
good duck in by Davis delivery by Reed
could be right yeah absolutely alley is
a good size Vanderbilt I think I've
watched The Equalizer movies as much as
any movie Davis knocks down the three 12
points here in the fourth quarter we've
only played just a little over four
minutes
round to Davis Davis in the paint scores
again 29 for Davis
and while the Lakers
trying to win here at home in this
important five-game home stand Davis
jumper that's good Anthony Davis 31
points
a good job of getting into the
basketball get everybody out of the way
and letting him win the matchup that's
good defense
[Applause]
here tonight
or today he's hits the free throw he's
seven of ten from the free-throw line
still two and a half weeks away perhaps
from Lebron James returning they need
games like this from Davis until the
final minutes so it can take some time
off if you have that lead you call it
walking the dog screwed her into Davis
flips it up and in Anthony Davis 35
points until the final minutes so it can
take some time off if you have that lead
you call it walking the dog screwed her
into Davis flips it up and in Anthony
Davis 35 points 81 from the line for the
season got a 35-point game
thank you
Davidson's two big free throws back to
four